ja und darüber spreche ich mit dem
politologen und militärexperten der
bundeswehruniversität münchen carlo
masala schon guten tag zu guttenberg
scholz reist nach kiew was sagen sie
endlich oder wie schätzen sie das ja
natürlich war der besuch schon längst
überfällig am ende dieses monats haben
wir den nato gipfel der staats und
regierungschefs
wenn scholz nicht gefahren wäre wäre er
neben makronen trage der einzige staats
und regierungschefs sozusagen dennoch
nicht gar nicht in kiew gewesen wäre
also von daher überflüssig
überfällig tschuldigung
gleichzeitig aber natürlich ist die
interessante frage was bringen diese
drei heute nach kiew mit
es soll ja er soll ja kein fototermin
werden wie olaf scholz sagt also muss
irgend etwas mitgebracht werden und da
wir gestern die waffen geberkonferenz
hatten also die ukraine kontaktgruppe
gehe ich nicht davon aus dass es
irgendetwas sein wird was kiew im
bereich der waffen haben will sondern es
wird es politisches sein das wird eine
unterstützung sein dieser drei
höchstwahrscheinlich für den
eu-kandidatenstatus der ukraine in dem
ein spiel haben wir gesehen makro
gestern in rumänien betont nochmal die
diplomatische lösung es wird
möglicherweise das drängen darauf sein
dass man so eine art mit drei
vorbereitet also sozusagen eine ein
waffenstillstand zwischen der ukraine
und der russischen föderation nicht
jetzt aber später aber dass man diese
gespräche beginnt und es kann
möglicherweise weil es angedeutet wurde
auch beim akku um die
sicherheitsgarantien gehen die die
ukraine ja im falle einer lösung dieses
konfliktes haben will unter anderem von
frankreich und der bundesrepublik
deutschland um vor einer erneuten
russischen aggression sicher zu sein die
müssen aber natürlich relativ robust
sein diese sicherheits
garantien denn bisher hat ja die ukraine
sozusagen ein bisschen pech gehabt mit
garantien absolut also das budapester
memorandum in dem der ukraine
territoriale unversehrtheit garantiert
wurde von den usa von großbritannien und
von russland ist ja 2014 von russland
sozusagen zerrissen worden und die usa
und großbritannien haben nicht reagiert
also es kann keine unverbindliche
sicherheitsgarantie geben es muss eine
sehr harte sicherheitsgarantie geben und
da stellt sich die frage wie wird die
ausgestaltet da spielt frankreich
sicherlich eine wichtige rolle weil
frankreich nuklearmacht ist aber letzten
endes reicht auch nicht das versprechen
möglicherweise die sicherheit der
ukraine zu garantieren wenn es nicht
materiell unterlegt ist und das ist die
entscheidende frage wie wird das
passieren trotzdem ist es so dass sie
lenski immer noch nach schweren waffen
fragt und bittet erfordert ganz konkret
artilleriegeschütze
1300 mehrfach raketenwerfer 500 panzer
das sind allerdings zahlen das sieht so
aus als könnte die nato selbst wenn sie
wollte oder die nato-staaten das gar
nicht liefern was heißt das denn dann
für den kriegsverlauf wenn das gar nicht
machbar ist ich glaube man muss sehen
dass eine maximalforderung ist und wenn
die zur hälfte erfüllt wird ist das
schon mal ein großer fortschritt das
problem ist dass wir gestern bei der
ukraine kontaktgruppe gesehen haben das
meines erachtens der westen in seinen
lieferungen jetzt so langsam an das ende
dessen gerät was er liefern wasser
liefern will also ich war nicht
sonderlich beeindruckt von der anzahl
von systemen die da verschiedene staaten
der ukraine versprochen haben und was es
heißt es ganz einfach folgendes die
ukraine kämpfen an einer 1200 kilometer
langen front sie kämpfen gegen eine
massive artillerie übermacht der
russischen föderation die sozusagen
immer wieder zulauf bekommt an gerät und
an munition ihm geht selber die
sowjetische artillerie munition aus das
heißt wenn jetzt nicht waffenlieferungen
substanzieller art sehr schnell in die
ukraine kommen dann verändert sich
dieser konflikt wirklich beendet aber er
verändert sich dann ergeht über
möglicherweise in einem partisanenkrieg
was wir uns alle hier in europa nicht
wünschen können partizan kriege was
würde das dann konkret bedeuten naja
also wenn die ukrainische armee jetzt
gegenüber der russischen armee verliert
die russische armee den don was besetzt
komplett damit dieser krieg nicht vorbei
sein dann wird die ukrainische armee zu
einer anderen taktik übergehen sie wird
sozusagen zu einer guerilla-taktik
übergehen sie wird versuchen die
russische armee in straßen und häuser
kämpfen zu stellen das heißt fehlende
waffenlieferung würden diesen konflikt
noch viel viel mehr verlängern und
würden ihnen noch viel viel blutiger
machen als die möglichkeit jetzt eine
große gegenoffensive zu fahren den
russen territorium zu entreißen nicht
viel aber den großen territorium zu
entreißen und damit die voraussetzung
für friedensverhandlungen momentan sieht
es nicht danach aus ganz kurze
einschätzung dann ist die derzeit so aus
als würde doch die russische seite
geländegewinne gutmachen kann ja
momentan sieht es so aus ist die
russische seite geländegewinne gut macht
diese feuersbrunst die die russen da
entfachen im don was die rollt langsam
aber beständig voran und jetzt sind wir
sozusagen in den entscheidenden tagen
und wochen dieses krieges was einen
weiteren verlauf anbelangt sagt der
militärexperte und bundes von der
bundeswehr-universität münchen carlo
masala vielen dank für das gespräch ich
danke ihnen